PAST.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I AM JOHN ROBERTS IN FOR
BRET BAIER.
THERE ARE SIGNS OF MOVEMENT
TONIGHT ON GUN CONTROL IN THE
BLISTERING REACTION TO LAST
WEEK'S SCHOOL SHOOTING IN
FLORIDA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS INDICATING HE
WOULD BE IN FAVOR OF EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE FEDERAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR GUN PURCHASES.
THIS COMES AT SOME OF THE
SURVIVORS ARE MAKING PLANS TO GO
TO THE STATE CAPITAL THIS WEEK
IN MARCH ON WASHINGTON NEXT
MONTH, AS THEY DEMAND CHANGE.
CORRESPONDENT STEVE CARRIGAN
START US OFF TONIGHT PARKLAND,
FLORIDA, .
GOOD EVENING, STEVE.
>> GOOD EVENING.
WE GOT OUR FIRST LOOK AT THE
ACCUSED SHOOTER IN COURT TODAY.
THE 130 POUNDER WAS IN A RED
JUMPSUIT RESERVE FOR THE MOST
VIOLENT OFFENDERS.
APPEARING IN COURT FOR A MOTIONS
HEARING, 19-YEAR-OLD SUSPECT
NIKOLAS CRUZ KEPT HIS HEAD DOWN
AND SAID NOTHING.
HIS PUBLIC DEFENDER SAYS CRUZ
WILL PLEAD GUILTY TO 17 COUNTS
OF FIRST-DEGREE MURDER IN AN
EFFORT TO AVOID THE DEATH
PENALTY.
FOR ANTIGUN RALLIES HELD IN
MAJOR CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
YOUNG PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON LATE
IN FRONT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
DEMANDING LAWMAKERS INTERVENE TO
STOP GUN VIOLENCE.
IN FLORIDA, THEY HAVE ANNOUNCED
PLANS FOR A NATIONAL GUN CONTROL
MARCH AND WASHINGTON.
>> OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS NEED TO
GET TOGETHER, OVERCOME POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES COME AND GET THINGS
DONE.
THEY NEED TO SAVE THE FUTURE OF
THE COUNTRY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SCHEDULED
A LISTENING SESSION ON
WEDNESDAY.
SOME SURVIVORS CRITICIZED
TRUMP'S WEEKEND TWITTER ATTACK
ON THE FBI.
"VERY SAD THAT THE FBI MISSED
ALL OF THE MANY SIGNALS SENT OUT
BY THE FLORIDA SCHOOL SHOOTER.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
THEY ARE SPENDING TOO MUCH TIME
TRYING TO PROVE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
AS THE WHITE HOUSE SIGNALS TRUMP
WOULD BACK CONGRESSIONAL
EFFORTS.
MARCO RUBIO URGED STATE
LEGISLATORS TO CONSIDER RED FLAG
LAWS.
ENABLING FAMILY MEMBERS OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HAVE GUNS TAKEN
AWAY FROM SOMEONE DEEMED TO BE A
THREAT.
THE FAMILY NIKOLAS CRUZ LIVED
WITH AFTER THE DEATH OF HIS
MOTHER TOLD ABC'S "GOOD MORNING
AMERICA" THEY SAY -- SAW NO
WARNING SIGNS.
>> EVERYTHING EVERYBODY SEEMS TO
KNOW, WE DIDN'T KNOW.
WE HAD RULES AND THE FOLLOWED
EVERY RULE.
>> THE NUMBER OF WARNINGS ABOUT
CRUZ THAT WERE MISSED CONTINUES
TO GROW.
INFORMATION THAT A SOCIAL WORKER
VISITED CRUZ AT HOME AFTER HE
POSTED PICTURES OF HIMSELF ON
SOCIAL MEDIA CUTTING HIS ARMS
AND SAY HE WANTED A GUN.
THE SOCIAL WORKER CONCLUDED CRUZ
WAS A "LOW RISK TO HARM HIMSELF
OR OTHERS."
SOME STUDENTS HERE ARE STILL
STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> I WAS TALKING TO MEADOW RIGHT
BEFORE THE GUNMAN STARTED
SHOOTING.
IT'S VERY SAD.
I KNOW SHE'S IN A SAFER PLACE
NOW AND THE ANGELS WILL BE WITH
HER.
>> THE SCHOOL IS EXPECTED TO
OPEN AT THE END OF THE WEEK FOR
TEACHERS.
IT IS STILL NOT CLEAR WHEN THE